now before we launch into this idea
which isn't introducing any new concepts
but inch is introducing a harder more
more rigorous way of working with the
knowledge that you know I just want to
stop and talk about this word proof for
a minute because it's sort of up here in
in noun form right when you prove
something what you've created is a proof
okay what does it mean to prove
something I'm going to give you a
definition for it okay and this
definition works across all different
areas right what you're trying to do is
demonstrate something that's true try
and demonstrate truth but you're trying
to do it in a particular way that
convinces someone else right so what you
need to provide is not just like here's
the truth but you need to provide some
some reasons right or some some
something that we all agree on that we
could say yes that makes sense right so
we're demonstrating truth by either
evidence or argument and and those two
can go together I suppose okay this is
what it means to prove something and
it's true in all different kinds of
areas that we study so I'm gonna give
you three examples right mm-hmm
we study history right we study history
we study the past you can prove
something historically how do you do it
what do you actually do to prove
something historically you go dig stuff
up right you find evidence it might have
to be archaeological it might have to be
sources and all that kind of thing right
so what we're looking for here is I'm
gonna say sources that's probably the
easiest way it might be like a rock or
it might be something that someone has
written etc that's how you do things
when you historically prove that
something is the case okay
what's another area another subjects
apart from this one that you do proof
you do you really do proofs in English I
don't think most people would go towards
okay so you can't you can't argue but
it's pretty hard to prove something in
English even if you can try right
because you can demonstrate something
might be you know plausible but
- I you something is true I know you
guys didn't debates at the moment I'm
gonna go with agnese idea of scientific
now well you have a scientific proof you
don't really go looking up it was what
someone said right like it's nice if
you've got some physicist and they said
that something was true but that's not
enough
just because someone said something is
not enough you have to do something else
what do we do in science in our labs
what do we do we do experiments right we
repeat them over and over and over again
and if the same thing consistently
happens we come up with an idea that
hopefully encapsulate that or wasn't we
call that start of an H we can't with a
hypothesis and if it supports the
experiments or the experiments for the
hypothesis we say yes proven okay but
then we have mathematical proof that's
all we're focusing on naturally in this
subject okay
now Jake you don't cause that for me I'd
appreciate that face when you prove
something mathematically the fact that
someone says something well the fact
that you can do this many many times in
it looks like it seems to happen and
repeatedly neither of those is
sufficient we is a completely different
tool we use logic now I put these one
two three in a row as if they're kind of
equal to each other but they are very
different and here's why in history if
you find new sources the things that we
thought were true you might have to go
back and say actually we we don't think
this was the case because we've found
new new evidence that suggests otherwise
right so you find new sources and you
can find things that were historically
proven and actually show that they were
not true at all okay in science I want
you to think about this what would be
the parallel here right when you know
something something that's
scientifically proven but then we
disprove it how does that happen
these suggestions
okay so you can have people in different
parts of the world and they find
different things that's kind of a
problem right let me give you another
example when I was in year 10 I learned
that atoms look like this this is what
my textbooks have maybe your textbooks
are odd enough that they still have this
okay but then we learned through more
and better experiments with more amazing
instruments we look actually an atom is
not like that at all and atoms a weird
timing why be wibbly-wobbly object where
you can't even know where the electrons
are they don't circle around and nicely
things like planets okay they just kind
of do this weird you might be here or
you might be there or you might be both
place at the same time okay so we
experiment we experiment better
so we disprove things right but
mathematics is different because logic
can never be disproven that's what sets
us apart that's why we are so obsessed
with proof because proving things in
mathematics once you prove something in
mathematics it's true forever it's never
distributes why we still look at
Pythagoras right Pythagoras theorem is
just as true today as it was the day was
written okay